all right so y know what we get started
so uh great to have become a leak down
here I'm talking about Thank you Thank
You Alfred so I would be talking about
because this is you know beyond
worst-case workshop so I so this is you
know this is about some work in active
learning that we have been doing and I
would be talking about what happens when
you go beyond the worst-case kinds of
feedback that we can get when we can you
know whether we can exploit other kinds
of feedback to learn better and this is
joint work with my students ji chang
chang and song by yon and my colleague
Suraj everything okay so the problem we
will be talking about and this is kind
of you know the basic problem that most
of machine learning deals with is
classification so at a very high level
what was going on here you have you know
X's and Y's your exes are vectors of
features and your wise are discreet
labels right so maybe your vectors of
features are things like what is the
word what are the words in an email why
is whether this is spam or not you want
to find a prediction rule in a class to
predict Y from X right so for example
you may want a linear classifier that
separates the spam form not spam right
so this is kind of the very basic
setting and what is a big problem in
building you know highly accurate
predictors in the setting well the
problem is of an acquiring labeled data
right so you can get you know my inbox
every day gets like a thousand emails if
you count the spam and that's very cheap
right but to feed this kind of you know
so to feed these into a machine learning
algorithm which can detect spam from not
spam you need somebody to sit down and
label these emails right so you need
somebody to sit down and say okay this
is pam that is not and so on and so
forth and if you're looking at more
complex tasks like you know like
labeling medical images and things like
that then it becomes it might be quite
expensive right so labeling getting
cables are quite expensive and what we
hope to do in active learning
is to get around this somewhat right by
using interactive label queries okay so
the idea is what you want to do is you
have a whole bunch of X's what you are
doing is you will you know maybe try to
get a few labels then learn something
based on that try to get a few strategic
labels and so on and so forth and the
hope is that in this process you don't
you know you don't need as many label as
many labels as you would have needed
earlier right and also your goal is to
find a prediction rule that will predict
the wives from excess using as few label
queries as possible right and so you
know for people who know this stuff I'm
being a little deliberately I'm being a
little vague over here but that's on
purpose and we will you know come back
to a formal setting in just a little bit
but first I want to give you some idea
about why active learning would help
right why are why would you conceivably
expect this kind of thing to help well
suppose this is your you know this is
the data you have you asked for this
label you get a red now you ask for that
one you get a black you ask for the one
on the top you get a red and maybe you
asked for this one and you get a red
right now there is only one linear
classifier that will fit these red and
black points right and this is your
linear classifier so so you know at
least in this high example we can see
that you know we didn't need the labels
of all these other points in white and
you know we just had to query for levels
instead of eight or nine and we got a
classifier from this okay but there is
of course a caveat and the challenge is
when your response mandir when the label
that gives you a label but the labels
are not you know so to speak correct
right so I'm putting incorrect within
quotes because you know we'll talk about
what that means right and so what
happens is you know if you remembered
you know we talked you know so this was
our example and now suppose the labels
look like this right so we follow this
classifier because we had gotten you
know these two red points and suppose
the labels look
like this here the best classifier is
actually the dotted line on the left
right the best classifier is not the not
the Northern Line you found and this is
actually quite dangerous because if you
once you found that line what you would
keep doing is you would keep asking for
labels of points which are very very
close to the side and it would keep kind
of focusing down on this local optimum
right you would not look beyond to see
that there was a better classified over
there right so this kind of sir so if
what could happen is if somebody gives
you an incorrect response that can lead
you down kind of a long kind of the
wrong path okay yes my treasure you had
all the labels dash problems and be
complete right that's that's true but
there are you know yeah sure but there
are other ways of there are relaxations
that we can use to solve but even in
some sense this problem gets accessor
baited when you are doing this active
craving some pointers trying to me okay
so now what I would be talking about is
you know so we are talking oh you looked
at label queries what I would be talking
about today is can other kinds of
queries help active learning right so
you know if you if you think about a
human who's giving you feedback the
human can give more than labels they can
do other things and you know you can
have you know a different setup and so
this is this is kind of an overall
agenda that we have been looking at and
it's not just us you know a lot of
people in the field are doing this in a
shy has some interesting papers on this
and you know about ur and and Sean joy
you know there's a whole bunch of people
who have been looking at this whole
field and this talk what I would do is I
would talk about you know two recent
works that we have done in this along
this lines the first would be when we
when you have an extra week labeler
which can you know which may be
sometimes it differs from this from the
labels that you want to get but maybe
it's you know sometimes it gives you
useful feedback and then the second I
will second thing I will talk about is
when you have labelers which sometimes
say I don't know right and I
look at this more formally for the rest
of the talk okay okay so let's look at
what happens with weak and strong
neighbors okay so let's start with
formalizing what kind of model you know
the kind of the learning model that we
are looking at the mall the learning
model that we will look at for this
particular problem will be the back
model of the probably approximately
correct I mean I'm sure many of you know
about this model but I just want to do a
quick recap right so here what happens
is you're given a concept class see for
example it could be the class of linear
classifiers and you're given samples
xinyi from data distributions your bone
is to find the sea in this class which
has no error okay so which has a low
probability of C of X not equal to Y
right so this is lower okay and this
this this term is called error okay so
there there are a couple of things to
note over here so the first thing to
note is you never actually see the data
distribution d all you have is samples
from this distribution right and what
you want to get is the probability you
know error is actually a distributional
quantity it's not just based on the
samples so my point is that not only do
you want to do well with respect to the
samples you see but you also want to do
well with respect to similar samples
from the same distribution okay and
under the pack model there are you know
two kinds of variance at they look at
and these are called a realizable and
diagnostic right so in the realizable
case what happens is we assume that
there is a perfect concept in see that
will perfectly predict your labels okay
so that is the realizable case right so
there is a linear classifier that
perfectly separated surpluses from the
minuses okay in that Nazi case there is
no such thing right so for example there
is this little island of minus over here
and you know whatever linear classifier
you have it's not going to predict
things perfectly but what we want to do
is we want to get the best linear
classifier that we can write this is
agnostic learn okay and what we will be
looking at for this specific section of
the talk is at Gnostic active learning
so here what happens is you have a Ponce
classy right and let's say you assume
that the best concept in your class has
some error new star and let's say you
don't know this everybody know it has
some wear a new star you are given
excise instead of Y eyes you can make
interactive label parties and your goal
is to find a concept in your class that
has low error right so which has let's
say error atmos new star plus epsilon
using a small number of label queries
and your goal is to have no assumptions
on the distribution right so the
distribution is what it is you find the
best that you can okay so what are the
different methods for agnostic active
learning so there are three broad
classes or methods and I won't go into
what they are in great detail so the
first is called disagreement miss active
learning a lot of people in the audience
have kind of worked on this so you know
I guess so these are all the citations
then there is a margin or confidence
based active learning and then there is
also some very nice work on clustering
based active learning I guess hi has
done some work on a descripton su margin
based active learning would be a bulk
and sang and vulcan along and
disagreement base active learning you
know balcon at all hanneke and so on and
this work what we will do is we will
just focus on you know we will look at
this agreement based approaches okay so
what is the main idea behind the
suburban base active learning what you
do is you will maintain a candidate set
of classifiers that contains the best
one right and basically your idea is you
know you maintain this candidate set and
you are looking to prune doubt that set
right as you get more and more label
label the examples you want to prune
down that set okay and you have an
unlabeled label unlabeled point that
comes in if there are two concepts in
your concept class such that C bond in a
concept c1 and c2 such that they
disagree on the label right so such as C
1 of X is not equal to C 2 of X so you
know let's say maybe once as spam the
others is not spam then you will
say that X is in the disagreement region
okay and you're going to query its label
ok and you query its label you update
this you know and based on the label you
update the candidate said ok and you
know as you can see this is a somewhat
conservative label policy right if there
any to classify set disagree then you're
going to ask for the label so this is
kind of a conservative label credit
policy ok and what we will look at is
what happens if we have some sort of
oxidative information as an extra Oracle
so for example what could happen is you
could have a doctor who is expensive but
who will give you the correct answer
whereas you know on the other hand you
might have a medical resident whose time
is less valuable but you know sometimes
maybe they're wrong ok and this is the
model that we will look at you know
again we have excise instead of you know
why eyes we can make interactive label
queries and these queries can go to
either the Oracle o or the weak little
RW ok and your goal is to find a
prediction rule that will predict Y from
X using few label queries 20 right so
for now we are assuming that W is free
and actually what happens is you don't
end up making that many extra quid he
stood up with you in our solutions you
know you end up making it if you use
standard active learning algorithms
however many queries you make their you
make more or less the same number of
credits to W so it's you know so that's
not a huge constraint but here our cost
is the number of Labor Code is so right
so for now we are assuming w is free and
you know your goal is to minimize the
number of label queries to 0 and
formally what would happen is you have a
concept class see where the best concept
has add a new star with respect to the
labels produced by oh right you have
excise and you can make label queries
interactive label queries to either
Oracle or the weekly blur w or even both
and your goal is to find a concept and
see which has error at most new star
plus epsilon with respect to O while
using as few label queries to 0 as
possible right so this is this is the
full formal model how do you specify the
quality of W yeah we were just coming to
that just that's an excellent question
you know I planted mantra in the
audience to ask me that it is coming
dude okay so what does this mean well
what this means is that the label RW
might be quite biased right so what
could happen is you know maybe these are
what the labels by all look like and
these are what the labels by W look like
right so they might the label RW might
be quite biased and what we will try to
do is figure out where the region of the
biases and then you know there we will
make query store so that's that's kind
of the that's the kind of approach that
we are willing to take and the way we
will measure you know how biased it is
or some terms that will come up
naturally we will see at the it was the
end yes that's 0 & 0 answers with
respect to a hidden concept a good
concert no oh good no not necessary not
necessary and W also not either w also
not either absolutely not yeah not
necessarily that's an excellent question
or does not have to be realizable with
respect to any concepts and W neither so
previous work there has been some
previous work on these kinds of models
then there's a work by owner at all and
in a shy in the audience who looked at
so what they were looking at is the case
where W would be wrong closer to the
decision boundaries and you know they
had some really nice results on it need
some work by eight ASA bianchi at all
who looked at who again had no aqui have
no explicit assumptions they again had
you know this kind of similar thing but
they looked at the online case and they
were looking at mostly regression
various various regression and robust
regression and in this talk what we will
do is we will look at a general strategy
in kind of this pack at Gnostic back
model for learning from WI know with no
explicit assumptions okay okay so let's
we have the model let's look at an
algorithm okay so what is the main idea
well the main idea is we will try to
learn a difference classifier which will
try to predict where onw differ and once
we learn this is front classifier H we
will use standard active learning along
with H right so we will use H to figure
out where they differ if the differ then
we will query or if they don't differ
then will query w right and so this is
the overall outline of the algorithm ok
so again if you write down this would be
the outline of this algorithm you know
you get these you know there's a bunch
of pick a bunch of points for each
points you query both of them try to
learn where they differ then you learn
to run stand at the sacrament based
algorithm and now the question is this
is statistically consistent in my head
that maybe Oh has one function of mine w
is another function sake I've already
query w a lot so I know w's function I
have that and then now I kind of want to
move from this one function i know that
some other function is kind of close by
absolutely accident that's it ask you
that question you said none of them has
a hidden hyperplane no but that function
may not be in your function class right
so the function that of REM is talking
about it's it's some implicit function
they have in their minds right on it may
not be a hyperplane it may not be your
concept class c strict w to be predict
at least consistent with a hyperplane
and 0 to predict consistent with a
hyperplane why do you relax oh it may
not always happen if you look at the
example of crowdsourcing yes if you
would place queries to the cloud you
will get answers for different
people in the cloud that were not be
consistent with anything it could be
like a probabilistic lately so the
function like if you were to query the
same point why'd you expect the same
answer so it's this to advice in this
part of the dog we do yes the next part
of the talk it changes a little by this
part video at all w give do they give
boolean answers so far now think about
it as boolean but they don't need to be
so this will also extend to multi class
yes if they are boolean once you have
learned H you wouldn't need to worry or
anymore you've just quit w and that H we
tell you it what you got is right in
which case you keep it or it tells you a
strong which guess it just complimented
that is true yeah that is true that is
true but the general strategy will also
work for non boolean
okay so the question is you know is this
going to work and our first key
observation in this paper it's actually
not right and what could happen is if
you directly learn a difference
classifier there could be this may lead
to inconsistent annotation okay so
suppose these are your actual labels by
oh right these are this is how old
labels this area and this is how w
labels this area right so all labels the
whole thing as yellow w labels that part
is gray and this is here okay and now if
you find the best difference classify
maybe look something like this okay now
if you annotate based on that difference
classifier that part you will query oh
right this is where the differ this
party will query w and the levels the
annotation that you would end up with
will look like this right so this could
lead to statistical inconsistency and
the reason why it leads to statistical
inconsistency is that the two kinds of
errors are not equally harmful right so
if if you say that they disagree whereas
they don't disagree that's kind of okay
right but if you say that they don't
disagree well as they do disagree that's
bad that can lead to biased annotation
okay so what you would want to do so how
do you solve it well the way we will
solve it is true you know at cost
sensitive classification what we would
say is we want something but the false
negative rate is very low you know close
to zero and subject to that we minimize
the false positive rate this and if you
use this kind of classifiers then that
will give you a consistent Angeles
issues particularly coming up because
you don't cuz toby is not in the class I
felt glad things would be easy you
basically learned it I'll be right
absolutely absolutely yeah that's
exactly right
so now our algorithm changes a little
bit instead of training difference
classifier registry and something with
Spall's negative rate at most epsilon
and what we can show is that this will
be statistically consistent okay so fine
so we talked about statistical
consistency next is you know by
statistically consistent I mean if you
keep making quite easy will converge to
the correct answer right so next is what
about the label complexity and what is
the label complexity here we are
measuring it by the number of label
queries tool okay so one thing to notice
is if you just did the algorithm that I
told you about if d prime is the VC
dimension of the difference classifier
an epsilon is your excess target error
then the number of labels you need to
train the difference classifier is you
know of the order of D prime over
epsilon right so that's actually a lot
of labels ok you know so you know that's
not really going to work so the question
is can we do better and as it happens we
can and that is the next key idea in our
paper okay the next key idea is so why
why do we need this difference
classifier well we are only going to use
it over the disagreement region of the
current confidence set where you know
current candidate said where this
classified is going to make queries
right and so we can sustain it over the
set and since this set is actually a
really small part of the input space and
you know we need a total error of
epsilon we can have you know over the
set we can we just need to learn it with
a false negative rate of epsilon over
the probability mass of this okay so
this is the second key idea which make
something work and what this means is we
need you know approx these any labels
right d prime times the probability mass
of art and you know our is the remember
artist a disagreement region of this of
this confidence at you know of this
plausible SETI candidates which is
progressively shrinking so think about
it as a relative small region and so
this this number is relatively small
also okay but again the problem is you
know your are will keep changing you
know as your confidence flight shrinks
the disagreement region keeps shrinking
and it will
changing so you know what we will do is
we will just keep retraining right and
we will retrain you know we will do this
doubling trick so if you know we'll have
an epic based solution and every epoch
we will retrain so this is the full
algorithm you have an epic based
solution let's say an epic e your target
excess air error would be about 1 / 2 to
the K you know you construct this
confidence at VK you know this plausible
set of classifiers which has this
agreement region and then you draw these
many samples so this number looks like a
bit of a magic but when it comes from is
this is how many samples you need to get
a classifier whose false negative error
is at most epsilon at most epsilon K
right so that's that's where that number
comes from and then you query 1w learn
the difference classifier and then you
can run your standard disagreement based
actively okay okay so how do we measure
the label complexity so remember we
talked about the disagreement region v
of asset is you know all x such that to
disappear right so what we want to do
here is we want to measure you know
basically the probability mass of the
disagreement region and we want to
measure how it you know the rate at
which it grows and shrinks okay and for
that you know previous literature and I
think honey cave was the one who
introduced it they have used the notion
of what is called a disagreement
coefficient and you know forget this
complicated math what does the sacrament
coefficient does is it measures how this
was you know kind of the rate of change
or rate of shrinkage of the disagreement
region as this you know as the diameter
of the candidates edge shrinks right so
you have a set of have a set of
classifiers V as its diameter shrinks
it's the said women region is going to
shrink and this is kind of this header
for I think of it as the rate of change
of that right so I think that's enough
for this stuff okay and as it happens if
you you know if you take this notation
the total number of labels to train that
decide the difference classifier would
be something like d prime time theta
which is a disarmament coefficient times
new
star plus epsilon over epsilon okay okay
so how about the rest of label
complexity well for that we have to make
some assumptions and this is you know
kind of the most technical part of the
top so the assumptions either we will
make is first of all there is a there is
a classified no difference class which
has basically no false negative error
very low false negative error over the
disagreement region and also this
classifier predicts low positives right
so the positives means that Otis
disagrees with W right I notice since
we're over the disagreement region this
number is at most the probability mass
of the disagreement region right so if
you are doing standard active learning
you would you know this number would be
the probability after the settlement
region because we are doing something
else this number is going to be you know
at least less than equal to ok and you
know once you plug this in we will get
some the sum of these two terms right so
d prime seta new star plus epsilon over
epsilon plus d x sigma nu star square
over epsilon squared okay where Sigma is
this you know is this other coefficient
which is less than equal to the
disagreement coefficient and if you
compare this with the sacrum and base
active learning what you would get is d
theta nu star square over epsilon square
ok and i'm sure i have lost a lot of
people here but there are two important
things to notice one is that that one is
actually a lower order term than this
right so this one has epsilon square in
the denominator and epsilon is a really
small number and that one has Absalom ok
the second thing to note is is that this
term Sigma so this is the same order as
this but Sigma the constant over there
is less than para less than equals its
head and you know it's less than you
know when it's less than theta then we
get the benefits ok so those are the two
important
kind of takeaway messages so so so
basically so this is a sister you know
so I guess in conclusion you can say
that if the disagreement region sorry if
the if you can learn the difference
region relatively well using some
difference classifier then you can get
benefits okay okay so now I'll switch to
the next part of my talk where we will
talk about active learning with
abstentions ok any questions before yes
just strip this little odd because it's
reasonable to think that your original
model might have a good linear
classifier and the week or who might
have a reasonable linear classifier but
the disagreement region could be very
nonlinear yeah but then they have two
different linear classifiers right right
just so it is not much the space of
classifiers will be relevant for trying
to learn the disagreement region might
be a much more complicated oh yeah
that's causing you to consider that's
absolutely true and however this that
that's absolutely true and you may not
have you know you mean we are not
assuming that you can learn it perfectly
first of all right so maybe there is
some error and also notice that you know
you still have the D prime V prime does
not have to be less than D right d prime
is the VC dimension of the disagreement
thing it does not have to be less than D
and the reason why we get away with it
is because here this epsilon term is you
know it's not it's epsilon is not
epsilon square so I agree with you that
you know if it's arbitrarily complicated
then you may get into trouble so I
probably do some condition but if you
have three of these could you have three
categories of
labelers no I you extend this more
complicated yeah I think you could yeah
I haven't you know this yeah I haven't
really thought about it in detail but
you could have something where you're
trying to learn pairwise differences oh
so I guess the the complexity of the
class of the disagreement hypothesis
would depend on the number of of the
size of the set P that you use the
active no no no no the disagreement
hypothesis is completely different from
the different classified let's take this
offline maybe okay okay so let's look at
the damaja the next part of the talk
which is abstentions ok so here what
happens is a you have a labeler right so
you know very often what happens is if
you have you know a non-expert label as
you know for example could be
crowdsourcing an example could be you
know even the previous example kind of
works what what happened is very often
you know you give a question to a
labeler and they don't know what to do
right and they will abstain and you know
the greater give you a completely
garbled label or they could just kind of
web stand right and the question is and
usually what would happen is when they
will abstain they'll have stain on the
more difficult examples and what we are
hoping to do is we are hoping to see
whether we can exploit this fact to
learn better okay so let's look at a
very simple example and a very simple
setting and so notice that I'm changing
tracks a little bit and now the model is
a little bit different let's say we have
a concept class c of just thresholds you
know one-dimensional thresholds and our
instant space is numbers between 0 to 1
right so it is a very very simple class
you know this one we should be able to
do and you know if he can do this maybe
we can you know we can also transfer the
insights to other things but so this is
kind of the simplest right so here what
would happen is you know you have some
ground truth c star right and the ground
truth is going to you know so maybe that
is your C star on one side you have
pluses on the other side your minuses
right that is
a brown food labeling and when you query
to learn in very pointy an article the
article can give you responses right so
they will give you responses you know
which may or may not be correct right so
maybe here maybe you queried it gives
you a plus here it gives you a minor so
you know the responses are corrupted by
noise here maybe it gives you at all yes
but you yeah but you don't see the when
you query you may not get it right it
may be corrupted by tonight yes that's
true okay and these responses are drawn
from some unknown distribution you know
which is P Y given X right so they can
be plus minus don't know and they're
drawn from some unknown p y given x and
your goal is to find a classifier see
that is close to c star with as few
queries as possible okay and and here
you know we are again looking at so this
is a slightly different model here you
can query any X so one difference
between the previa this under previous
model was previously you were given
access and you could query some of them
here you can query NEX in instant space
so this is what is called the membership
we remodel and your goal is to find a
see that is close to see star in a
geometric sense right so maybe hear the
difference between them is let's say
epsilon okay so let's see when can we
exploit abstentions right to understand
this let's let's start out by looking at
a picture right so suppose your petal
ice over over here right and let's say
this red line is your extension rate
okay so if you know so generally what
you would expect is you know as you go
up we could lose it to the decision
boundary you get hundred 100 examples
and you have state right but over there
this kind of flattens out right so here
I your extensions will kind of help but
if it's flat then you know your your
abstentions are not really going to help
you okay whereas if you have an
abstention rate which looks like this
where what happens is as you go towards
the decision boundary your labels you
know obviously they're going to get more
and more noisy but your abstention
it also goes up and what we are hoping
to do is we are hoping to exploit this
fact right so your extension rate
increases as you approach the decision
boundary and what we are hoping to do is
we are hoping to exploit this increase
to give us some you know signal about
which direction the decision boundaries
right so this is this is how we seek to
exploit abstentions okay so now let's
look at an algorithm so this is you know
we will start off with kind of the
simplest algorithm for active learning
in this setting right so the simplest
algorithm is binary search so let's
let's start with binary search right so
what we will do is will have some
interval so let's say we have a
plausible interval that contains c star
and we are hoping to narrow descent over
down right in binary search let's say
you're always getting the correct
response okay so you will query the
median of this interval right let's say
you get a response which is a plus now
you can divide the plausible interval
that contains c star by house right so
now you can narrow this down okay so
this is what happens when it's correct
and you know we all know the story in a
long one over after log 1 over epsilon
queries we can get down to our interval
of length episode okay now what happens
when you get a noisy response now if you
get a noisy response what you could do
is you can keep wearing this multiple
times right for each each point you
queried multiple times then you know you
call it enough that you can you know you
can average and you can get the ground
truth labor with high confidence right
so i won't go into the details you know
there's like a lot of you know
information theory literature on how to
do this sort of stuff right but you know
you could average and you know we can
get the ground truth label with high
confidence and you can still get a sense
of what the ground to labor was and you
can keep having okay and this will be
kind of the basis of our okay so how do
we extend a handle abstentions right so
we will handle abstentions by using a
variant of this binary search you know
modified by the research so now let's
say this is our candidate interval that
contain sea star instead of creating the
median what we are going to do is we are
going to query the quartiles of them
right so we will look at so this was our
interval this is a third quartile the
median and the first quarter right so we
look at the three four times and then we
will you know keep making multiple
queries okay and after each query so
let's say we make a bunch of queries
after its query we figure out you know
we'll run this adaptive hypothesis
testing and we will determine if we are
confident in the label at any of these
points or if the abstention rate is
increasing in some direction and we can
say this with confidence right so for
example here maybe we query so we get
you know 11 ? each and you know you get
some pluses and minuses you're not
confident of the label but what you can
say maybe confidently after some
hypothesis testing is here the
abstention rate is going up right and
then you can use this to narrow down
your interval okay so then you reduce
the interval correspondingly right so we
can use this method so this is kind of
the crux of our algorithm I don't have a
lot of time left so I would I won't go
into a lot of details but that is
essentially the cracks of the algorithm
and then you know we can do this
adaptive hypothesis testing and we have
to keep the epsilon San Delta's in check
okay so what can we say about this
algorithm we can actually do this
completely adaptively right we don't
need to know what are the parameters of
the noise model you know we don't need
to know anything we can just do this
completely adaptively and this algorithm
will give us the right answer so long
has the abstention rate does not
decrease closer to the boundary right so
if they've sent generate you know either
flattens out or Teebs gently increasing
it will converge to the right answer
okay but how about the number of queries
right so here we are trying to minimize
the number of ways when do we get a
benefit okay so we can characterize you
know kind of conditions under which we
can get a benefit but for the purpose of
this talk let me just give you one
example case where we can get a benefit
and an example is when your response
model looks like this right the
probability that you are outputting I
don't know condition on X is something
like 1 minus c 0 times the absolute
value of x
seastar to the Alpha right so notice
that when you are at sea star at the
decision boundary you are always saying
don't know and as you move away it goes
down right and alpha kind of describes
the rate at which it goes down okay and
you can also incorporate noise so your
noise model is a probability why not
equal to the ground truth labor is less
than equal to half minus c1 times X
minus C star to the better so you also
have you know some noise rate and that
is again the decision boundary the noise
rate is a half right so you are getting
complete garbage but as you go away the
noise rate decreases and you know you
can dumb and better describes how it
decreases and the number of queries that
you need to get c minus C star less than
equal to epsilon for our method it would
be epsilon to the minus alpha right so
here I alpha and beta are actually
greater than equal to 1 so epsilon to
the minus alpha is kind of a good thing
right and whereas if you threw out the
abstentions and you use only labels what
you would get is epsilon to the minus
alpha minus twice better right and this
is actually a slight extension of a
result due to Castro a no bag that you
would get 0 of e to the epsilon to the
minus alpha minus twice better so this
is this is going to be a bit worse so in
summary obsessions can help us if the
rate of abstentions increase close to
the decision boundary and you know
obviously we were looking at a very
simple thing the membership we remodel
and what we have been looking at more
recently is the back model which is some
work in progress so concluding you know
more complex feedback can help active
learning but you know under certain
conditions it's not really simple you
know you really need to you know you
really need to formalize when it helps
and obviously as you can see we need
fairly sophisticated algorithms though
you know it's not as simple as just
looking at the basic algorithms and
making some small tweaks in itself
yes yes now we get the question you are
talking about different cost models for
this label contacted me to evaluate
those active learning approaches but so
did their own based on the sort of the
model that you query one there one data
point and then you get a response and
you update and so on what about if you
want to query several data points at
once and then update the model after
that it if you could imagine that a cost
of querying multiple data points at once
could be lower than the cost of putting
one at a time that's an excellent
question actually the spa this thing is
you know this gap between if you had to
do what you're calling batch active
learning right versus like fully
interactive when you can always that is
not really that well understood so c1
sabato I think and some other they had a
very nice paper this cold about this but
this where they had some very cute
examples where this really made a
difference but you know even for basic
active learning this trade-off is not
really that well understood
you're real people write your your
algorithm is batshit that's true yeah
our says at least you need it's more
like epic batch right cuz hours every
epoch you could do everything in batch
but you have to do this gearbox get on
some
I think it's another thing would be so
you have like two classes of you know
week labelers and then the strong labels
you could have you knowing at the base
of how much you pay them they're they're
kind of better ah yeah that's that's an
interesting yeah yeah they put in more
effort yeah yeah that's a very
interesting question so there are a lot
of you know different models but I to
explore definitely yes so I've been said
that there could be another model where
you take the costs directly into account
so that you have a couple of laborers
but if you pay the more they may be
better that that's actually a very
interesting models that's the same 11
good the surfers that cost more thatís
where they cost less well it's not as
simple as good or bad I think the tricky
part here is to model why they're good
or why they're bad right often you know
like what is bad about the you know and
and your algorithm will be very tied to
that model right let's hear our model of
being bad was being biased if being bad
was being like just random noise there
would be a different algorithm also that
there's a difference between whether you
actually know that someone york weighing
is a good or a bad
you have to learn whether or not exactly
that that's the other that that's the
other that's that's actually be bigger
challenge right so your energy term a
may be good or bad but you don't know
until you have made several things life
this miss areas renovation problem